My iPad, for
the most part, has replaced my sketchbook.
And so in this video,
I'm going to show you three different ways
that I use my iPad for work.
Hey, guys, welcome back to the Channel.
My name is Dami and I am an architect
in Beautiful Vancouver, B.C..
On this channel,
we talk about architecture and design
and also some tools and strategies
that can help us have more meaningful
and fulfilling careers in architecture.
Paper is still a very big part
of my workflow, especially
when I'm working with my colleagues
or when we're doing design reviews.
And I do think there are certain
things like paper
and a fat marker just can't beat.
But after seeing some other architects
like Henry GAO or Eric Reinhold
Transform their workflow with the iPad,
I decided to get one for myself.
And over the last year or so,
it's become
a really essential part of my workflow.
I use a combination of procreate,
notability, click up
and PDF for work and I'm going to show you
how to use AI here.
One of the ways
I maximize the use of my iPad
as an architect
is with these graphic templates.
I created these templates
and brush presets
based on the things I use
every single day, and I've got things from
people and tree brushes to scale of paper
templates.
Basically, every time I start
a new project, I start with this
and it saves me tons and tons of time.
All of these templates that I'm using in
this video are going to be available
at the link in the description.
So the first way I use
the iPad is for design iterations
as a design tool
in the earlier phases of the design.
So when you're in the schematic phases
of the design, you don't really want
to spend too much time
fully developing one option.
You want to try doing multiple iterations
and spend that time to develop multiple
rough options.
And that's because you can have
a much better discussion this way.
Like you can talk about the pros
and cons of each option
and you can collaboratively pick
an option to develop more in detail.
Which is why in this phase, architects
tend to draw things out on paper
because you can think faster and draw
faster than doing it on the computer.
But the problem with this, of course, is
that hands get floorplans
are not nearly as accurate
as floorplans made on CAD or Revit
and it gets messy very fast.
I actually used to spend a lot of time
just drawing and redrawing things
because even though the ideas
were worked out
well, it just didn't look clean
enough to be presentable.
And I think we can all agree
the present ability of the thing
has a lot to do
with how your work is perceived.
Then there's the scanning
and printing again, and there's just
a lot of wasted time
and paper in this process.
So now with my iPad, almost all of these
inefficiencies have been resolved.
I use procreate
and I have a set of templates that I use
whenever I start a project.
I start with my skill paper template,
which I've set up in different metric
or imperial scales in different paper
sizes.
I have it on about 30% opacity
and you can turn it off before you print
or you can leave it on if you want.
We typically print in tabloid,
so this is the one that I use the most.
And because of these one meter grids,
I can get a much higher level of accuracy
much faster, even when I'm just doing
a schematic layout.
When I'm working on projects
with existing conditions.
I would model the building and Revit
based on the existing drawings
that are available and use the pdf
of the drawings as the base.
The best thing about using the iPad
is the ability to make options with layers
and easily go back if you make a mistake
without having to restart or erase things.
Once I've got the basic layout,
I have a set of skill
furniture elements that I can easily copy
and paste into the drawings.
Or I use these stamp brush tools
which I have saved onto
my Procreate app.
When I'm developing the elevations,
I add color and tone with a brush set
that kind of mimics markers
and you can overlay them
and the lines get darker and thicker.
And I feel like this
just adds a richness to the drawings.
I've also been collecting different
background images
that I've been using
to stylize the drawings,
and I don't use this too much
when I'm working, but I find that
it just adds another level of depth
when presenting it digitally.
And you can also play around
with materials with this as well.
When we move into 3D, as
soon as the design's been roughly modeled
in Revit, I take a couple of use of areas
that needs to be resolved,
and then I print a PDF of those views
and I use them as a base for drawing over.
And it's the same idea as the plans.
I don't want to spend too much time
detailing one option before
discussing it with your team.
You want to do a couple of iterations
to talk about the general direction
of the building rather than spending
all your time in one option.
The problem with when you're modeling
things on the computer, especially in 3D,
especially in Revit,
is that you tend to waste a lot of time
trying to resolve details
that are actually not that necessary
and like trying to make the image
look nice.
And I think there's something to be said
about the look of a 3D rendering.
Like a rough 3D rendering, in my opinion,
looks a lot less presentable
than a rough sketch, like a rough hand
sketch, even for internal reviews.
A rough hand sketch, by its nature,
feels more like a work
in progress,
and it's more open for discussion.
Because with procreate
you can just simply go back.
If you make a mistake, you're sketches
end up coming out a lot more
refined
and presentable than a sketch over trace.
Another way I use my iPad is for site
reviews.
Before I had my iPad, I would carry around
like a full set of drawings in one hand
and my phone in the other,
and I would be taking photos while
at the same time
trying to make notes on my drawings.
And a lot of the times I would be flipping
through the pages and walking around.
And if you're a very experienced architect
who knows the ins
and outs of construction,
you might not need the drawings as much.
But as a fairly new architect, you know,
I want to double check everything
and document everything.
As someone who's always been a little bit
self-conscious about going to slate Well,
because I don't always look like
I belong there.
I'm always kind of looking for ways for me
to look more confident
and feel more confident.
And so the iPad has been great for that
because I can have all my information
right here and during construction,
you will inevitably come across things
that you don't really understand.
But that's totally okay.
And that's what your team's there for.
But if you are on site alone
or you're still a fairly new architect,
one of the best ways to build
confidence is just to be overly prepared.
Like, read all of the RFI
before you get to the meeting.
And if you know that something's
being built while you're there,
try to anticipate the problems
before you get there.
And if I don't understand
something on site, I'll say something
like, Can you explain the problem
from start to finish?
And you might feel
kind of stupid at the moment, but most
people are more than happy to walk you
through the problem, and it actually makes
you look more thorough and like you're
taking ownership of the problem.
I have my
drawings and I upload them to notability,
which is basically just like a note
taking software.
And as I'm walking around the site,
I take photos
and I insert them directly into the pages
and from there
I can take dimensions and write notes
on the spine.
I'll also pull up,
click up on my split screen,
which is where I organize
all my project notes.
And throughout the weeks
I will make notes on any concerns
or things I want to check out.
When I'm on site and when I get there,
I can go through the list
and just check them off.
Sketching directly on the photos
is also the best way for me to communicate
with contractors or consultants because
they don't really need pretty images.
They just need the essential information.
But usually they needed that information
like yesterday.
So doing a quick sketch on my iPad
is usually the fastest way
for me to send off that information.
The most common way to use
the iPad is for markup.
We used to print tons
and tons of sheets of paper to markup
construction sets, but now we can just
mark it up on the iPad.
I use a simple PDF program to annotate
and I mean, yeah, that's pretty much it.
If you're interested
in that design process and how I develop
concepts for real projects,
I'll leave the video right here.
If you're interested in
any of these graphic assets that I use
with my iPad set up.
I have a fully downloadable template
from scale grids to trees to furniture
elements to people elements.
And I'll leave the links to all of this
in the description.
There are also other ways
that I use my iPad for architecture
and also for non architecture stuff.
So if you have any specific questions
or want me to make a video on anything,
just let me know down in the comments.
Remember to like this video
if you found it helpful and hit the bell
if you want to be notified.
As soon as I release a new video
and if you haven't subscribed, subscribe.
And with that
I'll see you guys in the next video.